These last couple examples we've
been creating HTML and inserting
it right into the DOM. If you
have any sort of security
background and you're probably
screaming, "Wes, you must
sanitize that data before you
put it into the DOM." If you
don't know what that means,
essentially when you get data
from a user, whenever you're
displaying data from a user, you
must make sure that the user
isn't doing any Sneaky Pete
stuff on you, and trying to
maybe insert an iframe, or an
image, or to do an XSS. Here
I've got an example. Let's
assume I took this first name in
the about me. I got that from a
database, or an API or something
like that, and the user had this
saved in their database.
They said, "I love to do evil,"
and they inserted an image to
Unsplash, which is allowed. You
can insert an image into your
bio, no problem, but they do the
Sneaky Pete thing here where
they say, "onload equals alert,
you got hacked," so when this
image loads, run this JavaScript.
That is the big no-no. You
cannot let your users run
JavaScript on your page because
then they could drain your bank
account, or delete your thing,
or post as you. They could do
anything. Imagine if you let
someone run JavaScript on
Facebook. You could unfriend
everyone, or you could look at
all of their messages, or send
nasty messages on their behalf.
Here I've taken the about me and
I've just popped it into HTML
and then I've set it into our
bio. I'm taking it, carte
blanche, putting it in, I
refresh, and I get this message, "
You got hacked." That is
what's called an XSS, across
site scripting, where we let
someone else who inputted this
data run JavaScript on our page.
That's really dangerous. The
solution to this is to sanitize
your HTML. That's another place
where you could use the tag
template. In creating all this
HTML here, I have all kinds of
inputs from a user. But before I
put it into my HTML, it's
probably a good idea to run it
through a sanitizer. I've
loaded it in this library called
DOMPurify. It's a pretty good
little library that we use to
sanitize. You can have all kinds
of options in here in terms of
what tags are allowed and aren't
allowed. There's all kinds of
sanitize libraries here. You
could make a sanitized tag
template and use this library
inside of it. I'm going to show
you how to do that now. We say
function sanitize, and again
that sanitize function is going
to take in the strings. It's
going to also take in the values.
Let's go and do a quick reduce
function, so return, reduce. It
takes in a function and what we
start with, and our function is
going to be an arrow function
that gives us the, I'm going to
say prev, next. Previous is,
what was the last iteration.
Next is, what's the current
iteration, or index, what is the
index there. Then we're just
going to return a string that
tacks all of those things
together. We've got prev. We've
got the next. We've got values.
I or nothing. You need to excuse
that this is wrapping on to the
next line. If I zoom out, you'll
see that's just one quick little
line there. Now, let's take
a look here. We take the
sanitize -- you have to spell it
right -- put it in front, tag
that template. Reduce is not a
function. Obviously we have to
say strings.reduce. There we go.
We still have, "you got hacked"
because we have not yet done
that. But instead, what we can
do is say const dirty, and then
this string right here is dirty
because it still has it's onload,
or iframes, or any of the other
nasty stuff people are trying to
do. But you can return...
We'll use this library here.
It's called DOMPurify.sanitize.
We'll sanitize the dirty HTML.
Now when I return that, let's
look at it before. This is
onload you got hacked. Now when
I refresh, see that unload has
been stripped out, along with
any other nasty stuff.
Obviously, you could do this
just with a function as well.
You could say DOMPurify.sanitize
and just wrap in there. I'm
showing you how you could
possibly create a tag template
so that any time you are
creating HTML in, I've put it
here, but what if they put it in
there? We could also put it
on our HTML. You can put this
wherever you need to quickly
sanitize something. Even if
you're using variables or not,
it's going to sanitize it for
you.